Good morning.
Welcome to toxic Google.
Uh,
we're very fortunate today to have with us,
Dr Jeffrey Kirschner,
uh,
to speak with us about,
the biotechnical biotechnological assault on Alzheimer's disease.
Uh,
like for so many of you.
this is,
this is something very personal to,
to me and,
and,
uh,
and to so many others.
Uh,
my mother,
uh,
had seven children,
a and a,
and went through a divorce and finally decided to get her college degree at the
age of 40.
She got her bachelors of science and nursing went on to get her master's degree
and then her Phd and taught at the university level.
Uh,
and then unfortunately in the course of her teachings was struck by this,
uh,
by this disease.
Uh,
and it's something that there's not much we can do about.
Um,
it's one of the reasons why you joined the board of directors at the Alzheimer's
Association,
uh,
and,
and colleagues with Jeff Jeffrey on that board.
Um,
but this is something that we really need to put a lot of effort behind.
And a doctor Kershner was here today to talk to us about what is going on,
uh,
with the therapies associated with this disease.
So a doctor,
Kris Kirschner is a senior medical director at Genentech and adjunct clinical
associate professor of neurology and neurological sciences at Stanford
University School of Medicine.
Uh,
he designs that oversees clinical trials of novel therapies for Alzheimer's
Disease and other neuro degenerative illnesses.
Uh,
while also maintaining an active clinical practice at an academic memory clinic.
He was also on the board of directors at the Alzheimer's Association of Northern
California and Northern Nevada.
He graduated from Harvard College and received his MD and phd degrees from
Washington University in St Louis.
And so please help me welcome Dr Jeffrey Kirschner.
Great.
Thanks very much Andrew,
and thanks to all of you for coming this morning.
Um,
so one of the things that I have the great pleasure of being able to continue
doing,
um,
despite my,
uh,
kind of two different day jobs,
one at Genentech and one at Stanford,
um,
is I get to continue to see patients.
Um,
and,
uh,
one a woman whom I saw a fairly recently is a 67 year old woman whose husband
died a few years ago.
She lives in Palo Alto by herself and in the family house.
Um,
her daughter,
uh,
lives,
has kind of moved on to Manhattan,
so lives in New York,
talks with her mom frequently,
um,
by telephone.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
her mom's kind of on her own out here.
She's gotten used to being alone.
She's got her nice happy life here in Palo Alto,
you know,
speaks with her daughter
by telephone complaints to her.
Why don't you come visit me more often.
Um,
and so in the midst of one of these complaining episodes are fine.
Her daughter says,
fine,
you know,
let's,
I'll,
I'll schedule a visit.
Let's come out and see you.
Um,
and so they,
they planned this wonderful weekend together so her daughter arrives.
Um,
uh,
I think it was on a,
on a Friday evening on a flight from New York.
Um,
sees her,
uh,
you know,
greets her mom in the evening when she gets to the house.
They have a nice long conversation.
Mom tells her about this great a farmer's market that's open on a Saturday
morning.
Um,
uh,
in,
in Palo Alto.
We're a,
apparently you can get like some nice brunch food.
And so they,
uh,
they,
they make this plan.
Tomorrow morning we're going to get up early,
go to the farmer's market,
we're going to have a nice brunch there.
Time to go to sleep.
Daughter wakes up in the morning fairly early.
She feels,
um,
looks around the house.
Mom is nowhere to be found.
She gets a little bit panicked.
I mean,
she gets out,
goes,
you know,
that looks like the car's gone actually.
Where in the world could her mom have gone?
Her mom hasn't sort of joined the cell phone revolution and so she doesn't have
a,
the daughter doesn't have any way to contact her.
Um,
a little while later around 11 o'clock in the morning,
finally,
you know,
daughters in distress.
Where did mom go?
Um,
11 o'clock in the morning.
Uh,
her mom pulls up in the driveway,
gets out of the car.
The daughter comes outside script mom,
where have you been?
You know,
we were going to go out to the farmer's market this morning and her mom turns
her since,
oh honey,
when did you arrive
on the telephone?
Over the past few months.
Um,
you know,
in retrospect now this is the daughter telling me this story in clinic with her
mother sitting next to her,
her mother having,
you know,
just some,
kind of,
you know,
makes excuses for how this could have happened.
And it's not such a big deal in her mother's eyes.
Um,
but the daughter in retrospect kind of looks over the past several months.
and yeah,
mom has been a little bit forgetful,
maybe hasn't been so aware of like what the date is and things like that.
Her daughter kind of been brushing it off,
but this event really,
um,
you know,
was different and really stood out in her daughter's mind is being,
something that's clearly abnormal.
So this is why they came to see me in clinic.
Um,
you know,
her mom's otherwise pretty functional.
She's maintains the household.
I mean,
she's,
you know,
each three square meals a day.
She is,
she goes shopping,
she's got her volunteer activities that she participates in.
She drives,
she hasn't been in any accidents.
I mean she's,
she's functioning just fine.
One of the challenges that we have as neurologist is when to sort of put the
label of a disease on a patient like this.
Um,
and Alzheimer's,
which is what we're here to talk about today.
Um,
we've come to understand kind of spans a very wide spectrum.
Alzheimer's disease actually starts in the brain years,
decades,
probably before the first symptoms hit.
Um,
and we'll talk a little bit about what those brain changes are.
and so there's this some kind of dividing line between normal and what I'll call
preclinical Alzheimer's disease,
which is that stage of the disease where you've got the brain changes but you
don't have any symptoms yet.
Um,
and I think the field is very uncertain about where this line is between normal
in preclinical disease.
At some point you start to get mild symptoms.
Maybe a doctor would call a patient,
um,
uh,
say that a patient has mild cognitive impairment where maybe their scores on a
memory test are now,
uh,
abnormal.
In fact,
this woman,
I subjected her to a memory test and in fact she scored abnormally on it,
but you know,
asking her every question you can think about,
about daily function and she's just fine.
There's nothing that she's missing in terms of daily function.
We call that prodromal Alzheimer's disease.
When you have,
you know,
some memory test abnormalities but you're able to hold it together.
Um,
and this thing that we call dementia is the very end stage of the disease.
And this is where you now need help from outside people in order to get by day
to day,
you can no longer work.
Um,
you might need help balancing the checkbook,
uh,
or just maintaining the house.
Um,
so we regard this as being kind of the end stage of the illness and you can
imagine that there's a lot of people out there who need help with balancing
their checkbook and,
um,
sort of maintaining their calendar and so forth.
Um,
and there was a day where we sort of thought that,
um,
you know,
when you get old,
it's natural that you lose the ability to do these things,
but that's not what the medical profession now believes.
We don't think that losing the ability to maintain your calendar or your
checkbook is part of the normal process of aging.
That is an illness.
The statistics are pretty striking.
So the Alzheimer's Association,
um,
is,
uh,
folks from our local chapter here with me today.
Um,
and,
uh,
they are the leading advocacy group for,
um,
for patients with the disease.
Um,
and every year they assemble,
uh,
statistics and these statistics are staggering.
These are the latest 2017 numbers.
So,
you know,
more than 5 million Americans,
um,
more people die of Alzheimer's disease than have breast cancer and prostate
cancer combined.
Um,
it costs an enormous amount of money when you take into account not just the,
uh,
the costs of caring for the patients and housing patients who need all this
extra help.
But also,
what about all those unpaid hours work that,
um,
that,
uh,
spouses and adult children have to put in for taking care of these patients?
So this is an enormous illness.
In fact,
I think that this is the greatest health challenge of our generation.
Um,
in many ways we've gotten on top of things like heart disease and cancer.
Neither of those is cured,
but they're well managed now and we have a good understanding of what the risks
are and to how to keep people alive without heart attacks and,
and,
uh,
in,
in cancer.
Um,
but Alzheimer's disease is the one disease that doesn't have any treatment
available that can stop or even slow the disease.
We really have nothing.
So,
you know,
I,
I attend this clinic and I take care of patients,
like the one I said in a lot of what I do is just educating them on what the
illness is.
But I don't do a lot of treating because we really don't have,
uh,
any effective treatments to offer.
So what are the symptoms?
So just like this patient,
uh,
the inability to,
um,
uh,
kind of remember things that just happened.
The inability to form new memories is sort of at the core of how this disease
starts in most people.
And this relates to a structure in the brain called the hippocampus.
This is where new memories are formed and it is the first place in the brain to
get the a distinctive changes of Alzheimer's disease at,
I'll tell you about in a moment.
Um,
these brain changes do spread to affect other parts of the brain.
And so therefore other cognitive functions like a language function,
visual,
spacial function and executive function.
All of these different so called cognitive domains end up getting affected as
the disease progresses over time.
Um,
now I do in my clinic get confronted with patients who come to me and save for
30 years.
Doctor,
I've not been able to,
uh,
remember the names of people that's not a disease.
Um,
I have trouble remembering people's names too.
so there's a lot of people who are,
you know,
worried about,
uh,
you know,
what they perceive in themselves to be cognitive weaknesses that doesn't
necessarily constitute,
uh,
in,
in illness.
Um,
what gets my attention is when somebody tells me about symptoms that have
changed over time,
especially over the past year or two.
Um,
that's,
that's what gets my attention.
So what is Alzheimer's disease?
It's actually defined by what your brain looks like in the microscope after
death.
So there's these characteristic changes of plaques and tangles.
Um,
these plaques are made up of a protein that we came to discover is called the
Beta amyloid protein.
So these plaques are in the gray matter.
It's in that exterior mantle around the outside of the brain,
um,
uh,
kind of sitting there between neurons.
It's the spheres of an aggregated,
um,
and there's a bunch of cells,
inflammatory cells kind of surrounding it,
but it's made up mainly just have this one protein separately kind of
surrounding these plaques.
And also in other areas of the brain that don't have plaques.
Um,
there are these other structured called tangles.
Tangles are an accumulation of a completely different protein called the tau
protein.
Um,
and,
uh,
it aggregates inside of neurons,
whereas plaques are outside of neurons.
Um,
so how these proteins come to be aggregated and what exactly the aggregation of
these proteins has to do with cell death is still a bit of a mystery.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's been about a hundred years,
111 years to be exact,
that we've understood that this is what the brain looks like in,
in the patient.
Uh,
in a patient with Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
it was in 1906,
the dollar was Alzheimer,
uh,
who's a German pathologist.
Um,
uh,
finally at a conference,
presented the findings from a patient,
I'll gust dieter that he'd been,
uh,
basically obsessed with for a number of years.
He met this patient,
um,
in an insane asylum and Frankford.
Um,
she,
uh,
you know,
had a number of,
uh,
strange symptoms including memory loss,
um,
that fascinated him.
She was only 51 years old.
She actually had a rare kind of Alzheimer's disease that you get as a
genetically.
So she directly inherited a gene for this disease from one of her parents.
Um,
this is an uncommon way to get Alzheimer's disease,
but it is a way to get Alzheimer's disease at age 51.
So he became obsessed with this patient,
found a way to basically be her pathologist at death,
and he,
it's kind of macabre,
but he was sort of waiting for this woman to die because he couldn't wait to
look at her brain.
And this is what he found.
He was the first one to describe these plaques and tangles.
So at this psychiatric conference in 1906,
um,
he presented this paper,
he was largely ignored at the time.
Um,
the story is that the talk that came right after him was on compulsive
masturbation and everybody in the audience was there to witness that next talk
and they were eager for Alzheimer to get off the stage so that,
um,
so that,
that next speaker could come on.
Um,
so his findings were,
you know,
largely ignored for quite a number of years.
And for most of the 20th century,
we thought that Alzheimer's disease was,
um,
a rare disease of young people.
And it's because nobody did autopsies on grandma.
All right?
We always thought that,
um,
old people,
uh,
have memory loss and that's just a normal part of aging.
Um,
but it was in the 60s and seventies kind of,
you know,
after the war that,
um,
people started doing more autopsies and kind of came to this realization that,
uh,
instead of being a rare of young people,
it's actually an extremely common disease of old people.
And it was in 1985,
you know,
as kind of the interest in Alzheimer's disease in the scientific community was
starting to,
uh,
to rise,
that finally somebody discovered that,
um,
uh,
the protein that was in these plaques cause these plaques were just spots on the
brain and nobody knew kind of what they were made up of.
Um,
this was when this a Beta protein was,
uh,
this amyloid protein was,
was discovered as the main ingredient in these amyloid plaques.
And after this to,
so this was a seminal discovery in 1985 and following that,
there was an explosion in the scientific literature.
This was at a time when we were starting to do protein biochemistry and cell
biology and,
and you know,
kind of the tools that,
um,
uh,
that biologist use to characterize proteins and pathways and so forth where,
we're now blossoming.
And so this whole,
um,
you know,
understanding of what the,
a Beta protein is kind of came to light in the,
in the late eighties and early nineties,
we understood that this a Beta protein was actually a sub component of a larger
protein that,
uh,
came to be called amyloid precursor protein,
not a very creative name.
Um,
and we came to understand that some cleavage events.
So,
so that amyloid precursor protein gets cut at two different places in order to
liberate this short a string of amino acids that is the,
a Beta peptide.
And that for,
you know,
probably reasons that are just kind of random and having to do with the
biochemical nature of this little a Beta peptide.
It tends to be a little oily.
It tends to stick to itself.
Um,
it tends to just glum up in these big,
uh,
globs that you see here.
The plaques are actually win a hundreds of thousands or millions of these
molecules have a Beta all get glommed together in this really dense,
um,
insoluble,
a blob that the brain just doesn't know what to do with.
And you know,
the discovery of all these pathways ended up leading to the postulation of the
amyloid hypothesis,
which is this statement that Beta amyloid accumulation is the primary cause of
Alzheimer's disease.
What was,
and this was revolutionary in the field.
And what was the evidence behind this?
Well,
first you could take it.
So now in the laboratory,
people took this,
a Beta protein,
dumped it onto cultured cells or a squirted it into the brain of mice.
And in fact it could induce neuro toxicity.
So this protein could kill neurons.
All right,
so that makes sense.
That's supportive evidence that,
that,
that amyloid is bad for you.
Um,
probably most compelling was science was a genetic evidence of the importance of
a Beta.
So remember I told you that that a patient from 1906 that that Alzheimer had
examined,
she had a familial form of the disease.
So,
uh,
it turns out that she had a,
a point mutation,
just a single,
um,
uh,
element or for DNA was changed,
um,
in a protein that,
uh,
that mediates one of those cleavage events and the amyloid precursor protein to
liberate a Beta,
it makes that protein,
it makes that enzyme work too much.
So basically it leads to an overproduction of the,
a Beta protein
and other piece of genetic evidence.
We came to discover that,
uh,
individuals with down syndrome,
down syndrome.
What is that?
That's trisomy 21.
That's where you accidentally get three copies of chromosome 21 instead of the
usual two copies guests where the amyloid precursor protein gene lives.
It lives on chromosome 21 and it turns out that individuals with down syndrome,
if they managed to live to the age of 40 or so and don't die of heart disease or
have other complications of their genetic syndrome,
um,
they,
uh,
we'll have a 100% chance of getting Alzheimer's disease.
All right.
So their brain shows the exact same changes as um,
uh,
the patient that Alzheimer's took care of.
And the same changes that you know,
that all of our,
uh,
older demented patients have.
Um,
so this genetic evidence is really compelling.
So just single genetic changes that lead to an overproduction of this one
protein or sufficient to cause Alzheimer's disease.
And so scientists really,
you know,
got excited about this amyloid hypothesis and,
and now we think we're on a pathway towards curing the disease.
Cause now we have the causative protein in the brain,
right?
Um,
evidence.
Kate,
you know,
we,
um,
sort of assembled this picture of how Alzheimer's Disease Starts,
that,
you know,
the,
the amyloid,
uh,
a hypothesis postulates that a Beta is front and center,
that accumulation of amyloid Beta starts when we're healthy and probably reaches
a near maximal level.
Uh,
by the time patients like this,
a 67 year old woman that I told you about comes to my clinic,
probably the level of a Beta and her brain was more or less maximal,
um,
at that time point.
Um,
and it,
it persists,
you know,
through the prodromal and dementia stages of the disease.
Downstream of that is the accumulation of that tau protein.
Remember I told you about the tangles that you see in the brain and eventually
that leads to neurodegeneration and symptoms are the last thing that happened.
Um,
couple of important things to notice from this graph.
One is,
uh,
sort of the optimistic view of this graph has look how resilient the brain is.
It can withstand a lot of amyloid plaques and a lot of Tau tangles before a
patient exhibits the first symptom.
Okay.
So symptoms are long delayed in time from the accumulation of the damage in the
brain.
Um,
the downside of this is that by the time of patient shows up in my clinic,
the brain sort of looks like a war zone.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
this might make it a little bit complicated to start treating the disease at the
point that somebody has symptoms.
So bear that in mind.
So again,
amyloid hypothesis here we are now in the 1990s and everybody in the scientific
field is super excited about the amyloid hypothesis and now drug companies.
Now.
So now we're getting to the biotechnology part of the talk.
Drug companies are starting to glom on to this and say,
Hey,
we've got a goldmine here.
We need to develop drugs against this amyloid protein.
It turns out that it's not so easy to create,
you know,
the kind of drugs that you put into a pill,
right?
Small molecules that you can take as a pill and somehow do something to this
amyloid protein to neutralize it.
That turns out to be not so straight forward.
Um,
but scientists like Dale Shank had this idea.
you know,
if,
if the problem is a protein,
we have this whole apparatus in our body to deal with bad proteins.
It's called the immune system.
What the immune system does is it recognizes bad proteins,
for instance,
proteins that come from bacteria or virus as a protein that's recognized as
being foreign.
And the immune system goes crazy when it's confronted with a foreign protein and
it has all these,
you know,
uh,
advanced mechanisms to try to attack that foreign protein and to get rid of it
and the most efficient manner possible.
So Dale Shank and others had the idea,
why don't we hijack the immune system,
train the immune system to think that a Beta is a foreign protein and we'll just
let the immune system do the hard work of finding all that a Beta protein in the
brain and get rid of it.
And so,
uh,
you know,
what he was able to achieve in mice,
scientists now in the mid nineties had created mouse models of Alzheimer's
disease based on these,
uh,
human genetic cases.
So you introduce in mice those same genetic mutations that humans,
uh,
who have familial forms of Alzheimer's disease have.
And Lo and behold,
these mice develop amyloid plaques in their brain and they get demented.
Um,
and so what if you administer a vaccine to these mice?
So a vaccine is a way of introducing a protein,
kind of showing it off to the immune system with flags saying,
you know,
foreign bad attack.
Um,
and,
uh,
by giving a vaccine with this a Beta protein to mice,
he was able to absolutely clear these amyloid plaques away.
It was beautiful.
These mice,
not only did their brains look normal,
but they also behave normally.
They did not get demented.
And so this was in 1999 this paper was published in nature.
Uh,
uh,
several biotechnology companies were already all over this.
They had amyloid vaccine's ready to give to humans.
And so,
uh,
that was actually being done in parallel.
So,
um,
the first vaccines were given to a group of humans.
The field was extremely excited and absolutely sure that this was going to be
the cure for Alzheimer's disease.
That,
that,
um,
this vaccine would do in humans exactly what it did in mice.
Do you know what happened?
Unfortunately,
about 6% of the people in these clinical trials got meningitis.
Now how did that happen?
You know,
in retrospect,
it shouldn't have been so much of a surprise because it turns out that patients
with Alzheimer's disease have,
you know,
such an abundance of this amyloid protein in their brain.
I mean literally milligrams of it.
If you could purify it out of one human brain,
there's so much of it there that if suddenly the immune system goes berserk over
a protein that's in super high abundance within the brain,
not surprisingly,
you set off a pretty bad immune reaction and you can imagine that having a lot
of inflammation,
a lot of immune cells going berzerk around stuff that they think is foreign
around the brain can cause problems.
So they had to stop this clinical trial early because of safety.
It was not safe to give people a vaccine.
Um,
the problem with vaccine is that,
you know,
once your immune system is trained,
you can't turn off the immune system.
Aside from getting people strong chemotherapeutics or,
or something,
you can't really stop the immune system from all this crazy attack of a beta.
So this was pretty disappointing.
Um,
we followed these patients,
um,
uh,
Ashley to death,
um,
because we were so curious about did the vaccine at least,
you know,
do something positive.
Unfortunately,
all of these patients,
their dementia continued to worsen over time and there wasn't,
you know,
uh,
the patients who received placebo or patients who got the active vaccine,
there wasn't really any difference in how they're all timers.
Disease progressed over time.
Um,
a number of them ended up passing away and autopsies were done in the context of
this research.
One interesting thing they found,
um,
you probably have a sense that when you get a vaccine,
sometimes it takes and sometimes it doesn't or sometimes it takes a little bit,
in other words,
your immune reaction against the vaccine.
It can vary and you can actually measure this.
You can measure the titer of an antibody response.
And so that's what they did in these patients.
Say they,
they looked at some patients who had,
um,
no antibody titer against a Beta people who had sort of an intermediate antibody
titer and patients who had high antibody titers against a Beta.
And they saw that there was actually an,
uh,
really,
tight association between that finding and the degree of amyloid plaques that
they found in the brain at autopsy.
In other words,
patients who had,
who in whom the vaccine really took well had hardly any antibody,
uh,
amyloid plaques to speak of.
Whereas patients who were either treated with placebo or in whom the vaccine
didn't really take,
they didn't have much of a tighter against a beta.
Um,
they had a lot of plaques left.
So this suggested to the field that the vaccine did what it was supposed to do.
It,
you know,
presumably help to clear amyloid plaques out of the brain.
But it was a little bit frustrating that it didn't seem to have any effect on
the clinical course of the disease.
So vaccines aren't safe.
Cause,
as I said,
you can't turn off the immune system once it starts,
but what you can do,
um,
and here's where companies like Genentech and others,
you know,
our,
uh,
really come to the fore as being important.
What you can do is to manufacture in antibody.
All right?
So when you give a vaccine,
you're relying on the body to generate its own antibodies against this foreign
protein.
But if you,
but you know,
you can bypass that and instead,
uh,
engineer your own antibody and we call that a monoclonal antibody when it's,
you know,
a single antibody that's manufactured in great abundance in,
uh,
in,
you know,
uh,
in a manufacturing facility like Genentech or Abby or you know,
one of these big companies has,
so you can engineer antibodies that attack a Beta.
And the Nice thing about this,
you know,
you put this inside of a,
of an IV bag and you administered it to a patient.
If a patient has a side effect,
well you can simply stop administering the antibody,
right?
So now you have control over the immune response.
You can shut it off if you need to.
And so this was exciting and now the field is excited again.
We now have the cure for Alzheimer's disease.
We're sure of it.
Bapineuzumab was the first drug of this next generation,
the first of these monoclonal antibodies that was tested at big clinical trials.
Um,
everybody was very excited about it.
No fewer than four,
uh,
Major Pharma companies were involved with this.
Wyeth and Alon kind of entered a partnership running these big Alzheimer's
disease studies are very expensive.
So it started off as a partnership between Alon and Wyeth.
I think Johnson and Johnson then got a stake in one of those companies.
And then Pfizer bought Wyeth anyway for different companies.
All had a hand in this.
Um,
everybody was sure that this was going to be,
you know,
a cure for Alzheimer's disease.
Unfortunately.
Um,
the results of two big massive international phase three clinical trials
revealed that there was absolutely no effect of this drug either on memory
function or functional abilities of these patients.
In addition,
there were side effects.
Remember that meningitis that happened with the vaccine.
So we saw brain swelling in patients who were given in some of the patients who
were given this antibody.
And probably it was part of the same thing as that,
you know,
the,
the quote unquote meningitis cases that happened with the vaccine.
This is just brain inflammation.
Okay?
So what we told ourselves in the field at the time was the reason that this
clinical trial was negative was because we couldn't get the dose high enough
without getting this side effect.
Okay.
We couldn't get the dose high enough to really clear enough plaques out of
people's brains in order to have that beneficial effect.
So we convinced ourselves that this approach is not dead.
All right?
It's just that the side effect ended up being limiting.
So surely there must be some way around.
Roughly at the same time,
Eli Lilly had this antibody called Solanezumab.
So what they tried to do here,
they engineered their antibodies so that it bound to a form of a Beta that was
less likely to kind of cause this big inflammatory reaction.
So they,
they really attempted to dial down that side effect so that they could hopefully
maximize the therapeutic effect of the antibody.
Okay.
The field is excited again and in fact there were no side effects of this
antibody.
It was safe.
This is great.
You can administer now antibodies against a Beta in a way that's safe.
That doesn't cause this brain swelling,
but unfortunately they're big too.
You know,
two big international phase three clinical trials.
Well-Run trials were negative.
No effect on memory,
no effect on daily function.
There was a little shred of optimism though.
Now who were the people that they enrolled in their trial?
It's actually the same kinds of people enrolled in the bapineuzumab trial.
These were patients who already had dementia.
They were worse than that woman that I told you about at the beginning.
These were people who could no longer live alone,
people who needed help with daily function,
and remember how I told you that's actually at a fairly advanced stage of the
illness.
When they looked at the subgroup of patients in their clinical trials who were
at the mildest stages at the start of the trial.
Right.
Cause you know there's a,
there's a bit of a spectrum of,
of patients who are enrolled at the beginning.
They're not all the same when they look,
when they slice the data and looked at the most mildly affected patients at the
beginning.
Um,
they saw benefit of the drug,
about a 30% improvement in those patients.
This was enough evidence for them to run a brand new phase three clinical trial.
And they came to an agreement with the FDA that they just would need one more
trial now conducted just in those mild patients.
Um,
and it read out about a year ago,
it was positive,
but the effect was so modest,
something like a five,
two at most,
a 15% improvement.
It wasn't enough to move forward because these therapies require monthly I the
injections 150 to $200,000 per year,
that your insurance company gets charged a five to 15% benefit,
add smart enough it's not enough.
And so they ended up deciding not to move forward with that drug.
Okay.
At the time that Bapineuzumab and Solanezumab,
we're,
we're doing that,
you know,
we're running those first generation clinical trials and other big discovery
came about in the field.
You know,
we used to have to wait till autopsy to know,
you know,
to be able to look at the brain to know whether a patient has amyloid plaques or
not.
Um,
but this great technology came into widespread use,
the use of an amyloid pet tracer.
So this is a technology where you can use a small molecule that binds with high
affinity to amyloid plaques and you radio label it.
All right?
So you inject patients with this radioactive tracer molecule that in a healthy
person finds nothing in the brain to bind to and it goes to your bladder and you
pee it out and it's gone.
Or in a patient with Alzheimer's disease,
it finds something to bind to and the brain and it sticks around,
right?
So you inject a patient with this,
wait 60 minutes,
put them in a positron emission tomography scanner that detects radioactive
emissions to ask the question,
did this tracer find anything in the brain to bind to?
And you,
so you can see some examples of pictures,
uh,
of patients with Alzheimer's disease compared to healthy controls.
One big discovery was that the patients who were enrolled in these initial
clinical trials in whom expert doctors like me,
had the opinion that this patient looks to me like a typical clinical case of
Alzheimer's disease.
About 80% of the time expert clinicians like me or right.
And about 20% of the time,
patients don't have any amyloid in the brain.
They don't have Alzheimer's disease.
They have some other illness that's making them demented,
but it's not Alzheimer's disease.
Well,
this is a problem if you're running a clinical trial in 20% of the people
enrolled in your trial don't even have the disease of interest.
So this was one big lesson learned and maybe this was the reason why some of
these early clinical trials failed
out of Kana Mab was the next big,
uh,
monoclonal antibody.
This is made by a company named by a gentle little company up in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
They tried to solve these sins of the past.
So they designed their clinical trial.
They required people to have amyloid pet imaging in order to get into the trial.
So they had to demonstrate positive evidence that they actually had amyloid in
their brain than in other words that they truly had Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
it turns out that there,
uh,
antibody does bind to the form of a Beta that,
you know,
might cause those inflammatory reactions.
But they decided as a company that they were willing to tolerate that if they
could somehow see some efficacy.
And they really tried hard with the dose because another reason why that lily
antibody Solon is a math might've failed.
They used a fairly low dose of it.
It turns out that it's really hard to get antibodies that you inject
intravenously to cross the blood brain barrier to get into the brain.
Um,
there's something like a 10,000 fold barrier concentration gradient between the
blood and the brain.
And so you have to really administer a boatload of these monoclonal antibodies
in order to hope that enough of it crosses and gets into the brain.
So in other reason why Solon is a math might've failed as their dose might've
been too low.
So,
so biogen tried to correct these sins of the past.
They enrolled patients who definitely had Alzheimer's disease and they really
tried hard to push the dose up as high as they could.
And now for the first time ever,
this was in 2015 at a big international conference where we saw these data for
the first time.
Um,
these data showed that increasing doses of the drug,
both that 26 weeks,
so about six months and at 54 weeks,
so about one year,
um,
produce reductions in how much amyloid is in the brain measured by that amyloid
pet imaging.
Right.
So you,
you know,
put people into the scanner at baseline to make sure they have amyloid in the
brain,
but then you put them back in the scanner at 26 weeks and at 54 weeks and you
see Ashwell reductions and how much amyloid is in the brain.
So their antibody is working at least biochemically to remove plaques.
This was incredible.
Nobody had ever shown this before in the field.
Did it help people clinically?
And the answer was here again,
for the very first time ever,
yes,
there was evidence of a clinical improvement.
So the CDR thing,
this clinical dementia rating scale is kind of a,
uh,
a summary of patients' symptoms.
And uh,
they were able to demonstrate not so much at 26 weeks,
but at 54 weeks there was a nice reduction and how much people worsened on,
on the symptom scale.
Now,
this was a small trial.
There were,
you know,
just small,
you can see the end size 31 in the Placebo Group,
23,
27 and so forth.
And the various treatment arms.
This is way too small to get FDA approval for a medicine.
You need to run a trial with hundreds of patients to really demonstrate that
this effect is reproducible.
So this was a small trial,
but it was the first time anybody has shown,
um,
an effect like this.
So,
uh,
a couple of big international phase three clinical trials are going on right now
with this antibody.
Um,
it does cause a,
that brain swelling that I showed you in a number of people actually dropped out
of this trial because they,
they got that brain swelling and had to quit.
They got sick from it.
Um,
and so the field is really waiting to see how to balance this side effect versus
any positive benefits you get with this drug.
And so,
um,
this is one thing to watch for in a couple of years time.
We're going to see this clinical trial readout and it could be revolutionary
in the meantime.
Um,
people have developed drugs that target these enzymes that produce a Beta in the
first place.
So there's this gamma secretase enzyme that makes one of those two cleavage
events that creates the a Beta protein.
Turns out that inhibitors of Gamma secretase are poisonous,
makes people sick.
Okay.
That doesn't work.
Um,
Beta secretase is the other enzyme that makes the second cut that liberates that
a Beta protein.
This inhibitors of,
of Beta secretase seem to be less poisonous.
Um,
and uh,
now a number of companies have Beta secretase inhibitors that are in clinical
trials.
And just last week there was a big conference in Boston clinical trials in
Alzheimer's disease.
Um,
and we saw for the first time publicly disclosed data from Merck who had one of
the first of these Beta secretase inhibitors.
Um,
and then unfortunately they reported negative data,
um,
in patients with mild to moderate Alzheimer's disease.
And they were able to show that in fact their inhibitor did seem to reduce the
amount of amyloid plaques in the brain.
So again,
by there's this disconnect between evidence that the drug was doing something
good biochemically,
but it wasn't able to produce any,
any benefits for the patients.
And so we're all wringing our hands and wondering,
you know,
is the amyloid hypothesis dead?
You know,
out of cannon Mab that biogen antibody looks promising,
but it was a small trial and we've been in this field long enough to have seen,
you know,
small trials that look really promising,
that just vanish when you,
you know,
bring it to a big international phase three trial.
Um,
so,
you know,
we've been in the field long enough not to get too excited and given the number
of failures of drugs that target amyloid,
a number of us are wondering,
is the amyloid hypothesis dead?
Um,
Tau is,
you know,
this protein that,
again,
it makes tangles.
The other main pathological hallmark of Alzheimer's disease,
it seems to be downstream of Beta amyloid.
Um,
and one attractive thing about,
um,
uh,
and by the way,
the towers and the Baptist had been fighting ever since the 1980s ever since
these proteins were discovered.
And the baptists have had the upper hand,
um,
for a long,
long time.
But you know,
the,
you know,
this decade has really been the decade of the tower sites.
Um,
because,
uh,
because of all these negative results that have come from a Beta amyloid trials,
um,
Tau does have some attractive features.
First of all,
it seems to build up in the brain not decades before somebody gets symptoms,
but at the same time that somebody has symptoms.
So this is attractive if there's a nice temporal correlation between the buildup
of a pathology and the symptoms that somebody has.
This says that there must be some kind of better proximity of Tau to the
neurodegenerative process.
And furthermore,
there's this nice correlation in space.
So the exact same brain cells that showed evidence of Tau pathology are the same
ones that are producing symptoms.
So we,
we know,
you know,
we know a lot about different regions of the brain and what kinds of cognitive,
uh,
things,
different parts of the brain subserve.
So patients with language problems,
we'll have,
you know,
uh,
problems in their left hemisphere where the parietal and temporal lobes of the
brain join.
And in fact,
those patients who have language problems,
in fact show Tau pathology right there,
right?
Where you'd expected not true of amyloid.
Amyloid does not show up in the right places in the brain.
So Tao has this nice tight relationship in time and in space to symptoms.
Therefore it seems to be more proximate to the symptoms are patients have.
And this is part of what makes it an attractive target.
And so now we in a number of other companies have drugs.
Now again,
monoclonal antibodies targeting tau and it's going to take some years for these
clinical trials to read out.
So what we've learned,
um,
so number of things we've learned that you need to not be shy about dose.
You need to make sure that you enroll patients who are early enough in their
disease where you know,
full scale neural destruction hasn't set in yet.
Um,
you need to make sure that you actually enroll patients in trials who actually
have Alzheimer's disease.
And so using these molecular biomarkers to characterize patients at the
beginning of a clinical trial is important.
Um,
things to watch for this base inhibitor,
this Beta secretase inhibitor called [inaudible].
This is from Merck.
This is the one that showed a failure in patients who were already demented.
They have another clinical trial that's still ongoing in patients with prodromal
Alzheimer's disease,
so a milder form of the disease.
Um,
and so even though we're now fairly pessimistic about this mechanism,
will see that trial readout,
uh,
fairly soon after that we'll see these big phase three trials about a Canon
Mao-b,
a read out that was the one that looked promising and the in the small phase one
study and now there's a couple of other antibodies crenezumab and Gantenerumab
that are testing slightly different mechanisms against,
against a Beta.
Um,
and then,
uh,
it's going to be a few more years in the future,
but we'll see these towel trials readout.
Um,
so hopefully this has been helpful.
You'll see,
I mean,
many of these trials actually reached the headlines in the New York times when
they read out as,
as negative.
And so you'll,
you'll see announcements of these trial results as they come in the coming
months and years.
And hopefully now you have a little bit of her perspective on,
um,
kind of the story behind,
uh,
where these,
where these treatments came from.
So I'll pause now.
I think there's five minutes left and take some questions.
Okay.
So we have a mic in the back.
I have a couple of questions,
but I guess I'll cycle around.
So the first question I had was,
um,
that these proteins,
the town,
the Ab must have some kind of function in the body.
So I'm wondering,
first of all,
why they exist in the first place in the body with function they fulfill and
then potentially by attacking these proteins,
what sort of side effects are there eliminating them from the body?
That's a great question.
Despite,
you know,
now many decades of research on the amyloid precursor protein and the a Beta
peptide that you know,
is liberated from it,
we still don't know what the heck it does.
Okay.
You can knock it out in mice,
doesn't have much of an effect.
Um,
you know,
we haven't,
other than brain inflammation,
we haven't seen other side effects of drugs that seem to the,
you know,
aim to get rid of a Beta Tau,
uh,
is a protein,
its normal function is to kind of sit on microtubules.
Microtubules are part of the skeleton of a neuron,
um,
that,
uh,
in the axons,
the long protrusions,
the wires,
uh,
from neurons,
these microtubules are sort of the backbone of,
of axons.
Tau Is this protein that kind of sits on top of that.
There are other proteins that also sit on top of it to kind of stabilize these
microtubules.
Towel doesn't seem to be unique.
If it's gone,
other proteins do its job.
You can not tell out of mice and the mice have absolutely no phenotype.
There's no symptoms.
They're normal.
Um,
so,
you know,
towel probably we,
I think we understand a little bit about what towel does normally,
but it's a redundant function to other proteins.
Um,
the amyloid protein,
we really,
again,
after decades of research really don't understand what it does normally.
If anything.
Hi,
thanks very much.
Um,
I had just two quick questions.
I was wondering if you can comment on the relationship between cardiovascular
disease and Alzheimer's and also the,
the role of Diet in sort of specifically like tumeric.
Um,
this impacts on Alzheimer's.
Great.
So risk factors for Alzheimer's disease include,
um,
uh,
cardiovascular disease and diabetes,
the Metabolic Syndrome,
this become so endemic in our society.
Um,
the relationship is a little bit unclear and it might be indirect.
Remember these pathological changes in Alzheimer's disease build up over decades
and there's a threshold effect,
right?
There's some threshold at which those biochemical changes in the brain becomes
severe enough that now you have symptoms,
a number of factors determine where that threshold is.
Other damage to the brain,
for instance,
to the brains of vasculature might lower the threshold.
So that a given,
you know,
a given amount of a Beta and tau that in one person doesn't cause symptoms in
somebody who has,
you know,
simultaneous damage to the brain,
chronic damage to the brain from poor blood supply because of high cholesterol
and high blood pressure and diabetes,
maybe that threshold is lowered.
So it could be an effect like that.
Um,
some scientists think that there might be a more direct effect on Beta amyloid
metabolism,
but I think that's less clear.
Things like diet and exercise,
um,
probably feed into it.
Also education level,
how much,
you know,
attending lectures like this in the middle of the day is good for the brain,
you form extra synopsis and uh,
make it possible for the brain to sort of weather damage a little bit better.
So there's a number of complex things that feed into that threshold effect.
Um,
but,
but you know,
but those things may not affect the actual accumulation of the amyloid and tau
proteins themselves.
So you mentioned,
uh,
that the treatment that was successful for rats but not for people.
Was that the,
the manufactured antibody or the it,
the immunization.
Everything that I've told you about today has cured multimers disease.
We have cured of Alzheimer's disease over and over and over again.
Uh,
what this tells us is that the mouse models are not great replicants of the
human disease.
Got It.
Okay.
Cause my,
yeah,
I was going to ask you,
uh,
if you,
if,
if any research has gone into what it might be different human brains
then mouse brains,
that is it like our defense mechanisms of our brains that prevent that treatment
from working right
on us.
It's a lot of things.
I mean,
the,
the complexity of the Oregon is much greater.
The genetics is obviously different.
Um,
and just the chronicity of the disease.
I mean a mouse only lives two years.
Um,
the human brain,
you know,
assembles damage from,
six,
seven,
eight decades.
Um,
and uh,
it's just,
it's hard to model that in a,
in a,
in a mouse.
Okay.
Oh,
my mother was prescribed Namenda by her,
a general practitioner,
which I know was not mentioned.
Is that likely to do anything useful in cases like this?
Good.
So there's four drugs that are FDA approved for Alzheimer's disease.
Namenda is one of them.
Um,
they're not ineffective.
These four drugs do something.
They squeeze a little bit more juice out of the brain.
They're what we call symptomatic drugs.
And that they don't change the inevitable course of the disease to worsen over
time.
They don't change the slope of the curve,
but they sort of shift the curve up a little bit.
If your mother were to run out of her prescription and stopped the drug,
she would drop right back down to the curve that she would have been on had.
She'd never taken it.
So it doesn't,
so these drugs don't fundamentally change anything about the biochemistry in the
brain or sort of,
you know,
the disease process itself.
And that's why we call them symptom treaters,
the,
the drugs and the,
but I mean the drugs are still good because they do something,
it's not enough though.
We need so called disease modifying therapies that actually interfere on the
biochemical progression of the disease and the brain.
Um,
and actually,
you know,
slow,
change the slope of the curve fundamentally.
And that's,
that's what these drugs purport to be able to do,
although none has been successful yet.
Okay.
So looking at the graph with the amyloid and the tower,
it like seem to pretty immediately clear that the tau correlates with the
symptoms as you mentioned.
Um,
first of all,
why wasn't that examined sooner and why?
Why weren't Anti Tau drugs developed in tandem with the antiamyloid ones?
Second of all,
uh,
in the mice,
you said they squirted the brain with the amyloid protein.
Have they done the same thing with the Tao and seen like if it's the combination
of those two proteins or is it one or the other that's actually causing the
symptoms?
So it turns out you can make,
you can present towel to the brain in a way that it's toxic also.
Um,
but you just ask a question that's at the heart of what has been a big debate in
our field for a long time.
Um,
why did the baptists have the upper hand for so many years?
Part of it as the genetic evidence.
So you tations in towel.
Yeah,
they actually caused dementia but they don't cause Alzheimer's disease.
They cause a different disease.
Ferno temporal dementia,
um,
that causes degeneration of very different parts of the brain,
very different symptoms.
It's a,
it's a different disease to Alzheimer's disease.
It's only mutations in,
um,
that amyloid precursor protein or in the proteins that metabolize it to create
the a Beta protein or down syndrome where you have three copies of that gene.
It's only those diseases that,
uh,
you know,
seem to cause Alzheimer's disease.
There's actually an Iceland,
there's a,
uh,
a family that has a mutation in their amyloid precursor protein such that it
cannot be cleaved by one of those two cleaving enzymes.
And they can't that in that family,
you cannot make the a Beta protein and those patients cannot get Alzheimer's
disease.
So there's this great wealth of genetic evidence,
overwhelming genetic evidence of the primacy of a Beta as a causative factor in
a d.
And that's part of how the baptists had this upper hand for so long,
despite that nice temporal relationship between talent pathology and uh,
and symptoms,
Tau was just regarded as being this downstream factor,
but not really the root of the disease.
That may still be true,
but as long as we're treating symptomatic patients tell might be a better
target.
Right.
And it seems like you could kill two birds with one stone,
potentially treat the other disease.
Right.
I mean,
I guess does the amyloid causes the symptoms or is it contributing to the
production of Tau,
which causes the symptoms to you?
Is there an answer for that yet?
Nope.
Ah,
great.
Thanks everybody.